[Music]
we
are seeing the results of the genocide
that canada committed here
751 unmarked graves
the roman catholic residential school
has impacted us
intensely but we are proud people
we learned how to not like who we were
[Music]
canada will be known as the nation who
tried to exterminate the first nations
now we have evidence we will not stop
until we find all of our children
this is global national with donna
friesen
another reckoning for this country
another horrific reminder of canada's
shameful history
on this site of the former maryville
indian residential school east of regina
lie hundreds of unmarked graves the
kaoisis first nation says ground
penetrating radar has detected
more than 600 of them possibly as many
as 751
flags now mark the site of each
suspected grave
many are spaced one meter by one meter
apart not all are believed to be
children the first nation says
adults may have been buried here too
some
used to have headstones that were
removed
the gravesite is is there
and it's real and if you were to see it
there are 751 flags
when you look at it we are treating this
like a crime scene at the moment
good evening and thanks for joining us
the former chair of canada's truth and
reconciliation
commission had said canadians should
prepare themselves for more discoveries
like the one in kamloops
this one is even bigger the unmarked
graves found on
cowas first nation in saskatchewan could
be more than triple
the number found in kamloops bc ryan
kessler has our top story tonight and a
warning the details in it
are disturbing the discovery of hundreds
of
unmarked graves confirms what members of
calluses first nation have known for
decades
the roman catholic residential school
has impacted us
intensely we are not asking for pity
but we are asking for understanding
we need time to heal and this country
must stand by us
investigators have used ground
penetrating radar to carry out their
grim
search it detected 751 unique radar hits
below ground
and while there is a margin of error the
chief says it's confirmation of more
than 600 unmarked graves
near the former maryvale residential
school we want to make sure when we tell
our story
that we're not trying to make numbers
sound
bigger than they are chief cadmus
delorme says it's not a mass grave
at one point there were individual
markers at the burial sites
but catholic church officials removed
them in the 1960s
delorme says that was illegal and the
site is now being treated like a crime
scene
another chief representing 74 first
nations in saskatchewan
says residential schools were canada's
concentration camps
the sites of crimes against humanity an
assault on a first on first nation
people we are proud people
the only crime we ever committed as
children was being born
indigenous barry kennedy remembers being
an altar boy at the maryvale
indian residential school and burying a
deceased
child we buried him out behind the back
of the
church he says school officials
inflicted sexual violence upon students
and one of his classmates disappeared in
the night he heared the begging for help
right no one would ever go and help
everybody was always too scared
and brian was one of those individuals
and just he never returned
the pope needs to apologize
for what has happened to the maryville
residential school
the archbishop of regina offered an
apology of his own thursday
pledging to turn the sentiment into
meaningful and concrete action
today's findings just shows the absolute
urgency of that work the need to do
everything we can to support calluses
and other indigenous communities leaders
say this is just the first phase of what
will be a process that takes
years to see through this is phase one
we're going to identify all the names we
can
using all the records we will put
a headstone and a name to each of them
permanent reminders of the horrific
legacy of residential schools
that canada will be forced to confront
with each future discovery of unmarked
graves
ryan kessler global news saskatoon
according to a 2017 university of regina
report there are more than 21 thousand
residential school survivors in
saskatchewan
the former maryville school was for
first nations children in southeastern
saskatchewan and southwestern manitoba
it opened in 1899 and was run by the
roman catholic church
according to the university of regina
the federal government assumed
responsibility for it in 1968
in 1981 the kawesa's first nation took
control
and the school closed in 1997. two years
later it was demolished but the church
and the cemetery are still there
beside that cemetery is where the
unmarked graves were
discovered there were about 140 other
residential schools in canada
to call them schools is actually a
misnomer indigenous children were robbed
of their language their culture and
their family connections
there was malnutrition and physical and
sexual abuse
and the lack of information about
missing children and accountability for
what happened persists to this day
as eric sorenson reports the path to
reconciliation remains
a long one just days before canada day
a dark and inexorable truth is unfolding
in this country
burial sites in saskatchewan and british
columbia may be just the first of dozens
still to be uncovered saint ann's was a
residential school in ontario
evelyn korkmaz a survivor i expect them
to find
bodies buried it would not surprise me
at all
this is what residential school people
have been saying for years but no one
has been
listening what happened at residential
schools is not new to the powerful in
this country
in 1907 cindy blackstock's organization
runs walking tours in ottawa
one landmark is the building where the
chief medical officer peter bryce
first brought to light inspections of
residential schools more than a hundred
years ago
for the department of indian affairs he
cataloged the horrors of children dying
in high numbers
he called it a national crime and he was
ignored
and children continued to die at
residential schools
how many of those deaths could have been
prevented had canada listen to the
advice
of their own chief health medical health
officer in 1907
he was the whistleblower that never was
listened to the harm she says is still
evident today
in perpetually poor housing and unclean
drinking water
it's not historical it's playing out
right now it's not enough for the
government to say sorry they have to
change their behavior
for many indigenous people canadians are
only beginning to recognize the trauma
that still needs to be addressed let's
have a discussion
so that we can move towards healing
because right now
we're not near healing if we can't even
talk about the truth of the genocide
that's happened in canada
the chief of the cowisest nation says he
wants a different future for his child
in canada one day hopefully when my
four-year-old is
old we'll have reconciliation
through and through through the spirit
and intent it's been a heavy burden for
children like evelyn korkmaz to carry
for the rest of their lives
no more promises no more words we need
concrete action now there are calls for
the records of
every residential school to be made
public a painful reckoning that is just
beginning
eric sorensen global news toronto
the discovery in kamloops has prompted
the u.s to investigate its own history
of forcing indigenous children into
boarding schools
it will seek to identify facilities and
sites where students may be buried
the plan was announced this week by the
first native american secretary of the
interior deb hailand
who says she felt sick to her stomach
when she heard about kamlins
i come from ancestors who endured the
horrors of indian boarding school
assimilation policies carried out by the
same department
that i now lead we must shed light on
the unspoken traumas of the past
no matter how hard it will be
native american boarding schools
operated from 1860 to 1978
hundreds of thousands of children were
forcibly removed from their homes
to be culturally assimilated many are
still unaccounted for
there is some support for those who need
it the indian residential school
survivors crisis line is available in
canada
24 hours a day the number is toll free
and you can speak in confidence
the number is 1 866
the federal cabinet minister in charge
of crown indigenous relations has
apologized for a text she sent to the
former justice minister who is
herself indigenous and who calls that
text
racist it started with this tweet from
former
liberal mp jody wilson raybould she says
with the horrific news out of
saskatchewan our collective call again
is for concrete transformative action
justin trudeau if you care enough to
make things right stop your selfish
jockeying for an election which no one
really wants
and do what you promised in 2018. she
then tweeted this screenshot of the word
pension with a question mark a text she
got from
former colleague carolyn bennett who is
now the minister of crown
indigenous relations with me from ottawa
is michael couture mike start with some
context for people about why
the word pension is so loaded in this
context
yeah it really is donna and that's
because wilson raybould has to hold on
to her seat until october of this year
in order to qualify for her lucrative mp
pension which
only members of parliament who have
served at least six years are eligible
for now wilson raybould says the comment
plays into racist stereotypes about
indigenous peoples
that they are lazy and only want money
it was a private text that was shared
very publicly but still something you
would not expect from the minister of
crown indigenous relations
who has served in that role since 2015
when the trudeau government was first
elected
bennett's office said the minister was
unavailable for an interview
but pointed to her apology on twitter
which read in part
quote i let interpersonal dynamics get
the better of me
and sent an insensitive and
inappropriate comment
we spoke to wilson raybull today about
the text and the apology
what happens to carol and bennett it's
certainly up to the prime minister
to determine but i think that we should
all
take pause that we have a minister of
crown indigenous relations
whose instinctive response is what she
sent
me over um text message
and i am not shy to call out systemic
racism where it exists
prime minister justin trudeau has said
there is no more important relationship
than the one between canada
and indigenous peoples however wilson
raybould says her experience
as a former minister suggests otherwise
to have as her instinctive response to
say something like that
to me and i haven't received a text
message from her since december of 2018
is reflective of some of the internal
dynamics
that take place within this government
wilson raybould says this incident and
the tragic events of this week
could serve as an opportunity for the
minister bennett and the trudeau
government
to look themselves in the mirror and be
a bit self-reflective
donna all right mike look a tour in
ottawa thank you
a forensic reporting to the downing of a
passenger jet over iran in january 2020
says iran's account
of what happened is disingenuous
misleading and
deliberately ignores key factors the
iranian military shot down the ukraine
international airlines jetliner minutes
after takeoff from the airport in tehran
iran claims it was an accident the
report revealed iran showed a blatant
disregard for air safety
by failing to provide any information to
airlines about its military activities
when it launched a missile strike
against a pair of u.s bases in iraq
hours before the airliner was shot down
foreign affairs minister mark garneau
says iran needs to make full reparations
for causing
the disaster there's a limit to our
patients in terms of
waiting for iran to get back to us uh we
are going to remind them
on a regular basis uh but
i i'm not going to give you an exact
date on
on when if they haven't replied to us
that we're going to move to another
approach all 176 crew and passengers on
board were killed when the plane was
shot down including
138 people with ties to canada
stanley cup fever is spreading through
montreal coming up habs fans hold their
breath for tonight's pivotal
game six
hope for the habs is almost palpable in
montreal tonight montreal canadians face
off against the vegas golden knights in
game six of the semi-finals and though
there are still some public health
restrictions in place the town is ready
to party
dan spector reports
la feite nacional also known as saint
jean baptist day
it's quebec's most important holiday a
time to celebrate the province's unique
culture
and the french language we're just kind
of a small population in the
millions of angathon and we're still
fighting for it because of covet the
usual parade was replaced by a series of
outdoor exhibitions at montreal's
cartier de spectac
and while usually you'd only see a sea
of blue and white flags
there's quite a bit more red around this
year too go
labs go as if there wasn't enough joy
surrounding saint jean things opening up
as cases fall
the city is ready to boil over with
excitement
about the montreal canadiens a win in
game six against the vegas golden
knights in front of the home crowd at
the bell center
would push the habs to the stanley cup
final for the first time in
28 years it will be the perfect scenario
joined
with the games tonight to have the abs
wins on the center about this
there's kind of a neuric moment there
there's no time for an interview at this
sports bar they say the game's been sold
out for over a week
we got here at noon to go without the
cache to see the game tonight
others have chosen the first come first
served model but that doesn't mean
people aren't trying to get reservations
i've had to put the phones on hold today
because it's just non-stop
facebook twitter um every form of
contact in the bar they've been trying
to get reservations meanwhile some
downtown electronics stores have boarded
up their windows
fearing post-game mayhem win or lose you
could feel the tension in the air
tonight let's hope that everything goes
fine
police will be out in force hoping a day
full of joy
ends the way it began dan specter global
news montreal
still ahead the search for dozens
unaccounted for near miami
this is what's left of a 12-story condo
building that partially collapsed near
miami florida
about half the building is wiped out
it's not clear how many people were
inside when it happened early this
morning
at least one person is known to have
died 99 others are still unaccounted for
my nephew was here with the
wife and three small children two
six and nine you never lose hope
i'm just asking god because they're in
the affected area
problem is the building has literally
pancaked there's just
feet in between stories where there were
10 feet that is
is heartbreaking
work was being done on the building's
roof but it's not known yet if that
played a role in the collapse
former minneapolis police officer derek
shovin is set to be sentenced
tomorrow in the murder of george floyd
he could face anything from probation to
decades in prison though a lengthy
sentence
is what's expected jackson proskow is in
minneapolis tonight
at the place where george floyd was
murdered there's a nervous wait for the
next move from the courts
all of america and the world saw what
happened
to brother george floyd just a few feet
from where we're staying in today we saw
a man
lynched in modern time and we want to
see justice
justice according to local activist
leslie redmond would be the maximum
sentence for former minneapolis police
officer
derek shovin in april a jury found him
guilty of murder and manslaughter
on friday a judge will decide how long
he spends in prison
anything less than 30 years is an
injustice it's a smack in the face
30 years is what the prosecution is
asking for
chauvin's defense wants no jail time
just probation
arguing in an unapologetic
pre-sentencing memo
that he was simply performing his lawful
duty in assisting other officers in the
arrest of george floyd
i just don't think he's going to
surprise everyone with a low sentence
tomorrow
law professor rachel moran believes
judge peter cahill will lean on the side
of a stiffer sentence
after finding aggravating factors in
chauvin's conduct
that allow him to go beyond state
sentencing guidelines
the defense knows very well there is no
way mr chauvin is going to get probation
and so to make that request is a bit of
a statement in itself
the state's attorney general has made a
statement of his own allowing
anyone to submit an impact statement to
the court to document how floyd's death
affected them
the court will also hear victim impact
statements from the floyd family
he was so much of a leader to us in the
household
similar to what george floyd's brother
delivered during the trial no matter the
sentence friday will not mark the end of
derek chovin's legal troubles he still
faces a separate federal civil rights
investigation
meanwhile the other three officers
involved in george floyd's death
will face their own joint trial in march
donna
jackson frosco in minneapolis tonight
thanks
stay with us global national is back in
just a moment
the news today from saskatchewan is
chilling and hard to take in
but it's not really news it's been known
for years that there are unmarked graves
and missing children
at former indian residential schools in
canada a report called unmarked burials
and missing children was written
six years ago for the truth and
reconciliation commission you can find
it online
it says death cast a long shadow
aboriginal children in residential
schools died at a far higher rate than
school-aged children
in the general population for just under
one-third of these deaths the government
and the schools did not record the name
of the student who died
due to limited government funding
students in most schools were
malnourished
quartered in crowded and unsanitary
facilities
poorly clothed and overworked students
who died at school were rarely sent home
unless their parents could afford to pay
for transportation the tragedy of the
loss of children was
compounded by the fact that burial
places were distant or
even unknown that is global national for
this thursday thanks for watching
we leave you tonight with words from
chief delorme from the cows
first nation about his hopes for the
future
in canada one day hopefully when my
four-year-old is
old we'll have reconciliation
through and through through the spirit
and intent so indigenous people and
canada
can thrive on this land together we
enjoy
working with canada we enjoy our settler
canadian friends and neighbors
what we don't enjoy is that life is
better off the reserve than on the
reserve
and we don't want that for our children
the truth is there
everybody has to reset
maybe the ignorance or the accidental
racism
that the education system has
told before it is already being changed
and investment in healing
from the core outwards has to happen
once truth is given and told
and accepted then reconciliation
will prevail